rob kardashian's vibe right now is just
living life and staying healthy for his
daughter dream that's like a main focus
of mine on friday a source told et that
the reclusive reality star is spending
as much time as possible with his
four-year-old daughter dream who he
shares with ex-girlfriend blac chyna
quote rob has been working on some fun
projects and is really mostly focused on
dream he's keeping things super low-key
he is very hands-on involved and super
silly as a dad
your tomato
tomato
tomato
no tomato
as for his health the source says rob is
continuing to work on it he still
struggles a bit with leading an active
lifestyle and it can make him feel
depressed sometimes it's just
frustrating to me that like
i'm not happy going out if i'm not in
good shape once if i don't get some
this together then i won't
want to like hang around everybody you
know what i'm saying and i want to our
source adds quote it's always a work in
progress for him but he's doing his best
to stay positive and healthy both
mentally and physically for the sake of
dream the kardashian family shared the
same sentiment back in june while
addressing robb's journey on keeping up
with kardashians and why he was hesitant
to appear on the show in later seasons
it's not so much about physical
appearance it's a lot of how he felt
internally about some of the women in
his life and how
they treated him or how he felt they
might have used him to get to certain
areas or levels and i think that really
affected him because my brother is such
a lover and has like the most incredible
heart and personality
um
and i think he's just getting stronger
and i think you you have to get
heartbroken and you learn from your
mistakes and i think he's just stronger
and feeling better to
be around to be more vulnerable or
exposed that same month chloe also
shared a rare photo of rob with sister
kylie jenner captioned soul mates
it's such a beautiful thing and earlier
this year another source told et ahead
of rob's 34th birthday that his path to
a sustainable healthy lifestyle was just
the beginning quote after his daughter
was born he committed to taking better
care of his health so he could have the
energy to keep up with her and the
benefits of that are visible
yeah that's cool